[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver ici au parlement européen à
bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo ou devrais je plutôt dire
hello ladies and gentlemen puisque nous
allons consacrer notre émission obr exit
alors quelles relations entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne après la date
fatidique du 29 mars 2019
que vaut l'accord négocié cette semaine
peut-il satisfaire les partisans du
breakbeat c'est compliqué pour la
première ministre britannique theresa
may qui enchaîne les critiques issues
même de son propre camp et puis les
entreprises ont-elles raison de
s'inquiéter à l'idée d'une sortie d'une
marché unique notre reportage à
retrouver en fin d'émission voici pour
le sommaire on va donc décortiquer ces
derniers jours très intenses à londres
et à bruxelles avec nos invités mais
tout de suite
on fait le point sur ce fameux accord
avec maïté frémont
[Musique]
c'était le 23 juin 2016
les britanniques disait au revoir à
l'europe deux ans et demi plus tard
après des mois de négociations l'union
européenne et le royaume uni commence
enfin à y voir un peu plus clair
voilà ce projet d'accord entre le
royaume uni et l'union européenne
c'est pas un document artificiel c'est
le résultat du benchmarking précis que
nous avons fait depuis des mois
avec cet accord prudent l'union
européenne a surtout décidé de prendre
son temps
ce qu'elle veut éviter à tout prix c'est
de réveiller une nouvelle crise
irlandaise
car en cas de sortie de la
grande-bretagne de l'union douanière
la province britannique d'irlande du
nord seraient concernés
ce qui ne serait pas le cas de la
république d'irlande qui elle resterait
dans l'union européenne est hors de
question pour les britanniques de
rétablir de fait cette frontière
la solution trouvée c'est donc de
maintenir un territoire douanier unique
non plus jusqu'au 19 mars 2019 date
officielle du bras exit mais jusqu'à fin
2020 et même au delà
l'accord prévoit de prolonger encore ce
délai au delà de 2020 jusqu'à ce que
l'on trouve ce fameux filet de sécurité
pour l'irlande du nord
personnellement je ne souhaite pas que
cela se produise je veux que les futures
relations puissent commencer dès le 1er
janvier 2021
les 27 ministres des affaires
européennes ont d'ores et déjà approuvé
l'accord
ce sera ensuite au tour des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement de le faire lors d'un
sommet exceptionnel ce 25 novembre à
bruxelles
et pour parler du brésil quatre invités
je suis ravi d'accueillir sur ce plateau
deux eurodéputés britanniques richard
corbett bonjour vous êtes député
européen britannique membre du parti
travailliste au royaume uni est ici dans
le groupe des socialistes et des
démocrates
david coburn bonjour vous êtes député
aussi européen britannique membre de
yuki et vous appartenait au groupe europ
de la liberté karima delli bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
française membre du groupe des verts et
enfin jean sébastien lefebvre
bonjourbonjour chef du bureau bruxellois
du journal en ligne
contexte alors priorité avoue notre
spécialiste des arcanes bruxelloises
on a l'impression que cet accord
finalement il ne fait que repousser les
problèmes à une date ultérieure est ce
que c'est ça finalement
non pas vraiment c'est l'accord qui a
été négocié entre les européens et les
britanniques c'est vraiment comment
faire sortir le royaume uni de l'union
européenne le mettre dans une zone grise
entre deux pendant deux ans et après moi
21 mois pour être précis et après du
coup pendant ces 21 mois on négocie la
future relation
donc on met pas les problèmes sous le
tapis c'est juste ont créé un sas un peu
de décompression pour permettre au
royaume uni de se préparer à la suite et
aux européens aussi avant de vraiment
complètement lâché le royaume uni vers
autre chose
richard corbett vous vous n'êtes pas un
partisan du breakbeat vous vouliez
rester dans l'union européenne
est-ce que cet accord c'est pas un
moindre mal finalement cette période de
transition
c'est un accord à l'aveuglé on va sortir
de l'union européenne sans savoir quelle
est la solution pour l'avenir quelle
sera la relation entre l'union et le
royaume uni c'est un accord bidon est
d'ailleurs de plus en plus de gens chez
nous contestent cet accord soit parce
qu'ils sont des ultras du bruch 6 soit
port beaucoup de britanniques parce
qu'ils contestent plus en plus même
l'idée du mexique
david cobain vous vous êtes favorable à
ambre exit dur qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cet accord il règle les choses
d'après vous il prépare vraiment la
sortie du royaume uni non ces scandales
et celle ci en bretagne et le prix mini
dans des décors avec les choses qui est
subjugué grande bretagne a les règles
sont députés son contrôle se compteront
pas des bureaucrates
je ne sais quoi mais ça c'est absolument
impossible pour convertir et les gens
s'est fâché aussi les gens qui avant
c'est pour pour l'instant d'un comité
local
maintenant ils changent pour break 6 10
on s'est fâché les comités de revin puis
il avait fait des ennemis en rompre et
allemagne on a vu qu'un des points
difficiles c'est la frontière irlandaise
vous vous dites quoi
selon l'union les femmes ont rétabli une
fronde cette frontière
c'est scandaleux frontière hollandaise
il utilise des communautés européennes
qui utilisent la tragédie qui l'ont du
nord pour tous
nous avons une frontière dur avec leur
public pas de problème avec ça
interpublic irait pas notre ami il nous
avons donc d'argent n'a lui il avait
fait qu'est-ce que ce possible pour
détruire notre bref si ça c'est pas la
réaction d'un ami richard corbett vous
essayez de la tête vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
david copains on dit on utilise cette
frontière irlandaise un petit peu pour
faire capoter
je sais bien puisque le gouvernement
britannique a déclaré qu'il veut quitter
l'union douanière forcément les
frontières deviennent des frontières
douanières
comment avoir une frontières douanières
sans contrôle douanier comment de faire
la même chose si on fait une frontières
douanières
évidemment il ya des contrôles c'est
inévitable ni les britanniques ni les
irlandais veulent le faire sur le
territoire de l'irlande
donc du coup il faut trouver une autre
solution c'est un vrai problème c'est un
problème et le dernière proposition de
madame m c'est de rester que tout le
royaume uni reste on à l'union douanière
revise rarement et entre-temps on va
réfléchir à trouver quelque chose
d'autre sais c'est pas une solution
évidemment karima delli vous êtes témoin
d'une opinion des britanniques très
divisé sur le sujet et en même temps
d'une europe unie l'union européenne qui
parle d'un seul mot sur le breakbeat
quand vous voyez tout ça vous vous dites
on joue aussi sur l'affaiblissement de
theresa may les divisions des
britanniques pour sortir renforcé du
président
pas du tout moi je crois que il faut
dire que le vrai site a été voté à plus
de deux ans maintenant ça fait des mois
et des mois qu'on négocie quoi un accord
finalement cet accord est conclu et
quand vous regardez les négociations
jusqu'à la dernière ligne droite
le lien de crispation c'était la
question notamment irlandaises et ça il
faut le dire pourquoi
tout simplement parce que justement la
véritable question c'est est ce qu'on
met une ligne aux données ou est-ce
qu'on remet une frontière terrestre la
frontière ts est inimaginable pour les
irlandais pourquoi on sait pas plus mais
loterie non c'est inimaginable pour
avoir fait ce qu'ils ont dans leur
histoire en 1997 c'était pas ya un
siècle
c'était à quelques années justement cet
accord qui s'appelle good friday
agreements qui dit ça y est on est
réconcilié maintenant sonné unis il n'y
aura plus justement de zones de conflit
donc maintenant la véritable question
elle est que les progrès qu site qui
justement lorsque l'accord est conclu on
a une theresa may qui va sortir à
westminster affaibli parce qu'on a des
ministres qui claque la porte
les progrès xi devons essayer justement
de un petit peu joué sur cette carte là
en disant on va la renverser manque de
pot ils n'ont pas réussi à faire un vote
de défiance au parlement britannique et
maintenant tout reste à jouer
pour theresa may pourquoi parce qu'elle
doit trouver une majorité pour faire
adopter justement celle dont parlera de
tous les appels à s'excuser moi je tiens
à dire quand même une chose qui est très
importante
vous avez dit l'europe et unia à 27 mais
c'est grâce à notre négociateur hors
pair et qui s'appelle michel barnier qui
a eu tout au long des négociations cette
volonté
et de ne pas affaiblir les deux
économies mais surtout de porter
justement les droits des citoyens
européens chez le bart mien qui est un
membre des républicains un homme de
droite mais qui fait plutôt consensus
jean-sébastien le fait sur la corde du
brésil complètement c'est à dire qu'il
ya eu quasiment aucune voix dissonante
au sein des vingt-sept sur sur la
question du bric site on a eu quelques
déclarations du ministre de la défense
polonais qui à un moment laissé penser à
des à une petite faille mais ça s'est
vite résorbée et michel barnier a su en
fait être à la fois ferme avec les
britanniques et toujours consulter tous
les gouvernements européens les par le
parlement européen d'aller voir aussi du
comité des régions
il ya vraiment fait la tournée en europe
de tous les acteurs importants est
maintenue vraiment un dialogue constant
david coburn vous avez entendu les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
affaires européennes des 27 pays 10 de
toute façon cet accord c'est ça ou rien
rien c'est meilleur pour nous n'est
anodine nous nous voulons nous devons à
deux il nous dit parce que qu'est-ce
qu'être mieux tiré l'union européenne
veut c'est c'est à nos deals bon ne veut
nous dire parce que ça ce qu'il n'aime
pas parce qu'ils avaient peur que nous
avons un grand succès a prévenu partir
de tous milieux tire bien et après le
new partiront les états liens et partir
après et maintenant il y avait un
mouvement populiste et ses petits il
connaît aussi comme adam a gagné les
élections eurent pillé et aussi elle est
contrainte au bief tire bien qu'à ses
yeux vous désapprouvez david caubère
exit ne fait pas d'exemple en union
européenne en laçant absolument pas
justement et fait peur et la raison est
tellement importante qu aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on a eu justement le vote libre
et xi de l'ensemble des pays européens a
eu peur qu'ils aient eu justement cette
espèce de chamboulement 10 ans chacun 20
et les domine alors que non là tout le
monde se serre les coudes ça c'est la
première et la deuxième chose qu'il faut
mettre en avant monsieur c'est que les
propres excite ont un peu agité les
peurs ont fait une campagne
incroyablement de démagogie et
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de plan
et quand vous dites mais oui on photo
retirer que ces terrains mais du jour au
lendemain si n'y a pas d'accord et moi
je milite pour qu'il y ait un accord
parce que s'il n'y a pas d'accord le 30
mars 2019 le royaume uni devient un pays
tiers et les conséquences
elle se rendra lui à télécharger lafosse
aimer les anglais de l'amica nomique sûr
pas fait un accord avec trompeta n'y est
aussi les animaux je prédis rapporte le
président el hadj localement ou de monde
il avait cru britannique s'élevait à
fait les accords avec d autres pays
comme les etats unis qui avaient déjà
offert
je suis désolé de vous le dire de
manière aussi brutale tout seul dans le
monde le royaume uni 7 à confettis
c'est notre politique pas notre ami il
note ennemis les americans enlevé on
voit mal comme de vrais visages des
mortels du break 6 fiche c'est l'extrême
droite c'est le support qu'ils agiraient
konami pour les corporations sans
restriction son règlement du tgv relient
des élites et de l'écriture
les écrits mais sans accord le vide
juridique du genre au monde ne faut-il
pas jouer tous ces petits cet accord
weezy plus que de risquer d'être
d'accord attention messieurs puisque
c'est un mauvais accord
outre les allemands seraient fait du
chantage aurait mis à les accepter mon
accord un mauvais accord où il n'y aura
pas d'accord mais l'autre solution c'est
de revenir sur la question du mexique
est de plus en plus de gens chez nous
selon les sondages d'opinion voudrais
rester dans l'union européenne ça c'est
de la vraie question
voyons minutes indique veut partir j'ai
fait de regarder tout d'abord cet accord
et effectivement il ne passe pas au
royaume-uni theresa may est isolé même
dans son propre camp regardez on en
débat après je suis sûr que nos invités
ont beaucoup de choses à dire sur le
sujet
[Musique]
theresa may doit se sentir bien seul
seul au milieu des 27 pays de l'union
européenne et seule chez elle au royaume
uni à peine le projet d'accord négocié
la première ministre a réussi à mettre
tout le monde d'accord contre elle vague
de démissions dans son gouvernement dont
le ministre justement chargé du
breakbeat
c'est ensuite au milieu de
parlementaires vos styles que theresa
may défend sa position
la seule possible selon moi l autre
chose c'est clair le choix est clair
nous pouvons choisir de partir sans
accord risque et qu'il n'y ait pas de
breakbeat du to you tube
[Applaudissements]
m
ou choisir de nous unir et soutenir le
meilleur accord que nous pouvions
négocier son camp le parti conservateur
est divisé les partisans d'un bris exit
durs vont jusqu'à la menacer d'un vote
de défiance
ce n'est pas ça le breakbeat c'est un
échec politique du gouvernement
il faut rejeter cet accord quitter
l'union européenne est une opportunité
fantastique pour le royaume uni
nous allons pouvoir diminuer les droits
de douane baisser le prix des denrées
alimentaires des vêtements des
chaussures aider les plus pauvres
mais cette opportunité gâchée et il y en
a d'autres qui pousserait bien theresa
may vers la sortie comme le chef des
travaillistes jérémy cornu le parti
travailliste votre à contre cet accord
et si le gouvernement n'arrive pas à
faire voter son choix par le parlement
nous exigerons des élections générales
c'est la seule solution sensée pour
déterminer qui va diriger le pays à
l'avenir
un deuxième référendum c'est aussi ce
qu'appelle de ses voeux l'ancien premier
ministre tony blair espérant que les
britanniques aient changé d'avis d
opposition unanime contre theresa may
mais très divisés sur l'avenir de la
relation entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne
[Musique]
à vous
et retour sur ce plateau pour poursuivre
ce débat sur le brésil
david combien on a qu attendez-vous
theresa may qu'elle déchire ce projet
d'accord dimanche
non je vois tu fais quelque chose pour
être poli je suis sur 10 ha mais elle
est finie à mon opinion tous les
ministères bon du beau ministère
il devait partir le mouvement et ça
c'est un signe que les gens séparés
heureux avec qu'est ce qu'elle fait et
aussi indiqué à mme hanoune odile ses
meilleures qu'un deal mal mais
maintenant elle avait change mais l'idée
est maintenant nous avons dit t'es pas
inclus
c'est pas un truc il becquerels
exigerait contenir les pêcheurs decosse
il est ce que c'est les dix nageuses
écossais se porte ça soit il est très
tardif et pêcheurs écossais richard
corbett vous vous avez parlé vous avez
une autre solution c'est organiser un
deuxième référendum pour vous l'opinion
publique britannique a changé d'avis oui
on s'attendait à ce que la foule
l'opinion publique allait se rallier
derrière le résultat du référendum que
les gens disent voilà on a eu notre
débat on a voté allons-y mais au
contraire l'opinion publique a glissé
vais régulièrement dans l'autre
direction ayant eu maintenant une
majorité contre le brick city la hausse
nos autorités
ce qui vous demandent un nouveau
référendum parce que le brésil ne semble
pas du tout à ce qui a été promis au
moment du référendum et les gens qui ont
voté pour quitter se posent des
questions mais c'est pas pour ça que
j'ai voté moi alors un nouveau
référendum ce serait une bonne solution
jean sélection à l'oeuf fc c'est la
solution finalement là on voit mal
comment la grande bretagne peut s'en
sortir faire en fait tu prennes du
deuxième référendum et dans le cas où
les britanniques disent que finalement
il veut rester dans l'union européenne
c'est qu'on sait même pas si on peut
arrêter processus de sortie marion du
losc a dit très clairement vous pouvez
qu'il est le président de l'institution
qui a reçu la notification du rang et
unique il va quitter l'union européenne
il a dit vous pouvez changer d'avis
jusqu'aux derniers mois mais avec l'air
techniquement ça vous laissons la parole
ça voudrait dire aussi qu'en gros là
première ministre britannique où le
premier britannique on verra qui sera en
charge ça arrive doit revenir à
bruxelles et dire pardon je me suis
trompé on s'est trompé garder nous mois
en terme d' humiliation politique et
international pour le royaume uni les
fléchages avec tout il ya déjà
effectivement rester sur est compliqué
mais là ça voudrait dire pour revenir
revenir quasiment à genoux en disant
c'est pitié s'il vous plaît on veut pas
sortir je donne la parole à karima delli
une minute je reviens vers vous
justement on voit quand même les
divisions au sein de la société
britannique même au sein des partis dans
votre parti il ya des progrès existent d
antibes résident pareil chez les
conservateurs
comment on peut s'en sortir un mot
justement sur ces divisions un pays qui
est aujourd'hui vraiment tiré en deux
vous avez raison on vit une véritable
crise politique au royaume uni c'est ça
qui vous dire maintenant la véritable
question est les clés abrite sitter
aujourd'hui sont un peu vus comme des
amateurs voire il vous est affaibli
parce que vous n'avez pas réussi à faire
cette motion de défiance qui aurait pu
renverser
theresa may ça n'a pas été possible et
d'un côté on a des travail et savez j'ai
encore bing qui tease noueront on ne
veut pas de cet accord donc maintenant
la véritable chance pour theresa may eh
ben c'est d'aller au front c'est son
moment de vérité pour l'europe
il va falloir qu'elle cherche les voies
pour que cet accord soit passé notamment
au parlement britannique david cobourne
ne vous dis pas les âmes est finie mais
la regarder elle est toujours en poste
il n'y a pas eu de vote de défiance
montrent elles proviennent des
référendums si nécessaire toujours
certes riche de myrtilles obtient chaque
fois il parut de réponse démocratique il
veut il fait écho à un autre référendum
un autographe ont fait ça ont annoncé
annoncé par les autorités
demande en mairie
c'est à berne autorités terry a
complètement oublié dans les années 70
aurez vous ferra attendez laissez moi
paris dans les années 70 au royaume uni
a eu un référendum pour adhérer à
l'union européenne non non non c'est une
chose allons pouvoir avec un drapeau
nord de canon met à nu pas d'accord avec
ça c'est juste pas d'accord
économie seulement ça et il riche et les
légendes urbaines et manor d'une durée
c'est émotif et tous les ministères tu
connais que ces actes riche karima delli
c'est ça le problème finalement c'est
que le royaume uni a toujours vu à
l'union européenne comme un grand marché
sans vouloir faire vestiaires davantage
c'est un peu ça c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'union européenne
et un espace pas seulement un marché me
soutient un espace de droit de liberté
et on se rend compte et les britanniques
se rendent compte aujourd'hui qu'en
quittant et en ne préparant pas parce
que les arbres et sitr c'est ça ils ont
menti aux citoyens on repère
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
plan b parce que si demain monsieur et
vous pouvez me dire tout ce que vous
voulez le 30 mars 2019 s'il n'y a pas
d'accord les conséquences économiques
et moi je le vois s'il vous plaît je le
vois parce que je suis la présidente de
la commission transports au parlement
européen il va falloir vite s'organiser
mettre en place justement une nouvelle
frontière au port de douvres au port de
calais ça demande énormément de contrôle
et donc des augmentations parlant de 50%
sur les prix en administratif ça va
avoir des conséquences sur les prix en
angleterre puisque ça va avoir des
conséquences sur les prix aussi
concernant par exemple l'ensemble des
entreprises pourquoi aujourd'hui toutes
les entreprises britanniques disent
athées les a mais s'il vous plaît
justice un accord
karim est bien parce que justement les
conséquences seront dramatiques
justement à propos justement de parler
maintenant des conséquences économiques
au royaume uni certains ventre certaines
entreprises s'inquiète à l'idée d'un
bric dur et puis bien de l'autre côté de
la manche on espère aussi récupérer
certains marchés le reportage est signée
françois dumoulin
[Musique]
le sujet a enflammé les médias de
l'autre côté de la manche
depuis le référendum sur le brésil en
juin 2016
la city est en ébullition les
entreprises les banques les
investisseurs tous menace de quitter
londres
la première place boursière d'europe les
sièges sociaux pourraient s'envoler vers
le continent
si les conditions du président sont trop
durs la banque d'angleterre a estimé que
5000 emplois seraient menacés et pour
émigrer vers l'europe en cas d'un accord
trop contraignant
clairement la forme que prendra l'accord
entre le royaume uni et l'europe nous
dira combien d'emplois seront touchés à
long terme
face à l'incertitude les entreprises
maintiennent la pression sur le
gouvernement britannique
airbus évoque dans tous les médias ces
quatorze mille jobs en péril bmw menace
de fermer des usines
ubs et hsbc disent préparer leurs
valises
mais les petites entreprises plus
sensibles aux tourments économiques se
posent également des questions
olivier guillotin travaillent à londres
son entreprise s'occupe d'aménager les
vitrines des grands magasins eux ont
choisi de rester malgré l'orage mais
craignent de payer cher le break site en
cas d avoir sûrement des taxes à
l'entrée des pays va y avoir des
difficultés pour recruter employés des
européens et
je pense qu'en cas de crise la première
chose que les consommateurs vont couper
ses dépenses au restaurant également
acheté de nouveaux vêtements ou sais je
vais la consommation de tous les jours
donc évidemment nous on peut s'offrir en
tant que petite entreprise ici au saut
en avant certaines entreprises
françaises ont déjà pris les devants
face à une possible menace la start-up
eric bonnet était installée il ya encore
quelques mois au bord de la tamise voix
sinon nos bureaux parisiens depuis
maintenant quasiment un an
l'entreprise a choisi de revenir à paris
pour rapatrier ses activités financières
menacées par une économie britannique
envers nous avons une activité de
gestion qui nous amène à prêter de
l'argent et la santé ces emprunteurs est
très directement
lié au contexte de l'économie puis
l'économie meilleur plus nous avons des
chances de recevoir les intérêts sur
l'argent que nous prêtons ou les
remboursements de capital
le fait que le royaume uni soit dans une
incertitude économique forte rend cette
activité un petit peu plus risqué paris
espère récolter les fruits de cette
fuite des cerveaux la ville la région et
l'état ont mis les petits plats dans les
grands
une cellule a été spécialement créée
pour séduire les entreprises
britanniques
donc là vous êtes au sein de la cellule
choses par les régions il chez unique
qui a été créée fin 2016 par les
autorités publiques politique française
c'est un soutien à la fois aux individus
pour les aider sur les démarches en lien
avec les écoles internationales la santé
le logement
et puis également tout ce qui est les
problématiques que rencontrent les
entreprises c'est à dire comment est ce
que je crée une société en france c'est
quoi les problématiques j'en ai dit que
les procédures également de liens avec
les autorités de régulation
pour l'instant seuls quelques centaines
d'emplois ont quitté la capitale et une
poignée d'entreprises a rejoint le
continent londres reste une place
financière et économique solide mais de
nombreuses décisions sont suspendues aux
évolutions politiques du breakbeat et au
contenu de l'accord entre l'union
européenne et l'angleterre
[Musique]
on va dire un mot évidemment sur ses
conséquences économiques mais l'heure
tourne alors on fait faire assez
rapidement
david coburn les entreprises disent on
va être obligé de partir du royaume uni
il y aura des emplois en moins est ce
que ça vous inquiète
le centre du monde finances jan cees
londe n'importe quand beauty y retient
il ya des inquiétudes au royaume uni
c'est la question économique qui me
posent le plus d'inquiétudes ça pose en
effet de beaucoup d'inquiétude on a vu
dans le film je sais que monsieur qu il
pense avoir mieux que tu fais et sur la
banque d'angleterre que tous les gants
les cornes face financier que les
entreprises productives c'est pas ça mon
secteur financier qui mens tu quittais
on a vu les autres l'automobile
l'aéronautique
c'est une menace grave pour l'économie
britannique c'est insensé de foncer vers
ce break 6 qui est totalement fou et à
côté de ça karima delli les pays comme
la france disent eh bien vous êtes les
bienvenus on essaye de récupérer aussi
les marchés des royaumes unis de manière
un peu opportune mais non mais parce que
justement nous on est quand même les
voisins et on est l'aîné la première
porte du royaume uni la france et donc
les grandes entreprises britanniques
elles pourront tout son rôle toujours
s'en sortir sur les frais de contrôle
douanier il ya 180 mille pme qui elles
ne pourront pas et ça il va falloir
aussi que nous la france on s'apprête
aussi à accueillir ben justement des
nouveaux salariés un dernier mot jean
sébastien lefebvre l'europe c'est un peu
vous avez voulu partir tant pis pour
vous c'est ça mais c'est surtout faut
aller au bout de la logique pour montrer
ce que c'est et après dans le rapport de
force il est évident dans le sens où 50%
des exportations britanniques dépendent
de l'union européenne mais dans le sens
inverse c'est seulement 10 12%
donc on joue avec les mêmes cartes et il
alla le rapport de forces est plutôt
insolite émissions et dizaine d'hommes
deux shows comme on dit en anglais
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir accepté
notre invitation un merci particulier à
nos deux invités britannique vous n'êtes
pas d'accord mais vous avez accepté d'en
débattre ici merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis et vous retrouvez notre émission
sur nos trois sites internet
lcp point fr public sénat et la rtbf
merci à vous
[Musique]